sergio fajardo nació en medellín en
el docente matemático y político fue
elegido alcalde de su ciudad natal en
2003 cuando terminó su mandato cuatro
años después el índice de criminalidad
había disminuido lo que elevó su
popularidad al 80 por ciento
en 2010 fue la fórmula a la
vicepresidencia de antanas mockus ex
alcalde de bogotá la capital y quien
perdió en segunda vuelta ante juan
manuel santos-
luego entre 2012 y 2015 fajardo fue
gobernador del departamento de antioquia
hizo de las cuestiones sociales y
educativas su prioridad su gestión
urbana y desarrollo fue galardonada por
la universidad de rotterdam en 2018
fajardo se postuló a la presidencia por
primera vez quedó en tercer lugar con
poco más del 23 por ciento de los votos
ahora aspira de nuevo llegar a la casa
de nariño de la mano de la coalición
centro esperanza para acompañarlo
designó al luis gilberto murillo
exministro de medio ambiente durante la
administración santos como su fórmula a
la vicepresidencia
además ex gobernador del departamento
del choco uno de los estados con la
mayor concentración de población afro
del país el dúo pretende representar el
centro con el objetivo según medios
la tradicional división izquierda a
derecha
[Aplausos]
libre de los puestos libres de los
contratos libre de las influencias que
no deben ser parte de la política
queremos convocar a esa colombia la
colombia que tiene talento que tiene en
riqueza la colonia que sabe muy bien que
la educación el conocimiento el
emprendimiento la cultura son los pasos
que tenemos que pasar esta página
sus críticos de izquierda le acusan de
querer perpetuar el sistema neoliberal
bajo la apariencia de la moderación
mientras que la derecha asegura que
apoya a la izquierda en un claro reflejo
de la polarización en el país que sólo
se dirimirá en las urnas